the Joe Rogan experience a lot of the
people who were amazing athletes who
they didn't start out vegan they weren't
born you know to vegan parents and then
we're vegan growing up and then you know
had made all these amazing records and
performance they built their strength or
their agility or their speed or whatever
on a diet with animal products and then
at some point they became vegan and you
know maybe their performance continued
and they continued to do well like Scott
Jurek or Dottie Bausch or maybe they had
the vegan honeymoon where they did well
for a while and then they declined or
maybe they just declined like some of
the NBA and NFL athletes we talked about
but this is a critical point because
there are key developmental periods when
we're kids and also in utero that like
if you're not getting the nutrition you
need then it's gonna carry through to
your whole life yes and so it's like
what did your parents see what did what
did that your mom eat when she was
breastfeeding you what did you eat as a
young kid so we follow that whole
argument through if everyone becomes
plant-based it's gonna have a huge
intergenerational impact on performance
it's not like people who built their
strength and performance eating meat and
then they go vegan they do okay for a
little while it's like what are the
consequences of that happening to have
without consequences of growing up
nutritionally deficient yeah of the mom
starting that way and then you know
getting pregnant and becoming deficient
during pregnancy and then the baby being
breastfed by a mom who's nutrient
deficient and then the kid being fed a
vegan diet and developing beet b12
deficiency which then becomes
irreversible effects are there any top
of the food chain world champion vegan
athletes they like the best of the best
well there's no there's no vegan UFC
champions there's no world champion
vegan boxer so there's Ilya iliyan do
you know him he's the weight
weightlifter that's I think in the same
weight class as Kendrick Farris who was
in the film mm-hmm
and two-time Olympic champion where I
don't I don't think Kendrick is one he's
not won a gold medal but he was stripped
of his titles because he tested positive
for steroids
so once again you know right what's
happening it's hard to say what he was
pulled from the film because that right
yeah he was pulled from the or was he in
the film I believe he was originalist
right now that you brought this on yeah
that's not a good narrative for them
right right and then you had like Tim
shieff if I'm pronouncing his name
correctly he was he's like the free
runner parkourers gonna be in the film
and then he had this very public I'm not
vegan anymore because it was destroying
my health video on YouTube he ate a
piece of salmon and had a wet dream for
the first time in a decade
okay I mean it was like poor bastard
yeah he was doing everything pot he did
a 30-day water fast
yeah he like he tried everything to stay
on the vegan diet yeah it wasn't like oh
it's hard I'm gonna eat salmon I should
also tell you he thinks the Earth's flat
Oh does he
yes yeah yeah a bit that could be the
vegan diet all those years rottenness
[ __ ] brain yeah well one of the main
guys you know the the anthropological
argument that humans are herbivores
because we don't have claws and sharp
teeth that all comes from Milton Mills a
1987 paper from him he's an emergency
room physician he has no training at the
medical anthropology or comparative
anatomy or anything like this
he is a creationist so he thinks that we
were just built less way and with these
jumped in the way by God so yeah that
that whole why don't we this if we are
carnivorous species why don't we this
how come we don't have the teeth to that
you know how come you can't just grab a
squirrel and eat it I've actually heard
a guy say that well hey [ __ ] how
come you can't eat lentils you got to
boil them yeah like what are you talking
about man we could try eating cassava
without cooking it you'll die signe yeah
poisoning yeah it's like that argument
is so stupid there's a lot of
plant-based foods that are only consumed
after
cooking yeah I mean going back to your
question I'm sure there are high level
vegan athletes but the thing is a lot of
the people who are commonly referred to
like the vena the the Williams sisters
Serena and Venus they're not vegan yeah
why do they have their in the film they
showed them in the film and I was like
wait a minute they're not vegan because
they're often people often call them
vegan they occasionally will have
periods of veganism I guess they're not
vegan they eat meat they eat animal
products look like Tom Brady is another
example another one who looks like a
meat-eater who who you know really does
eat a lot of you know you know
predominantly plant-based I guess but
eats meat especially in the winter the
Williams sisters are so powerful I mean
it would be a great like catch for that
team right if they were vegan it's like
look at the athleticism that these girls
have yeah but nope
but it was weird they didn't say they
were vegan they just showed them and so
you're like oh they're the best they
don't need to say it yeah that's it well
Simon
Arnold he's talking great about veganism
I can't run [ __ ] it to you right now
driving into a nice juicy area bye come
on show me a picture where is he doing
oh that [ __ ] epicMealTime he did a video
with them like five years ago you know
eighty thousand calories steak and egg
sandwich Jesus Christ Arnie
when there's this ostrich eggs ago oh
that's five years ago brother that's a
long time I could be all vegan I guess
but I doubt it
he was doing this while they were doing
the new Terminator movie you know as a
James Cameron movie he's not stupid
college boy and even if he is now he
didn't you know he didn't he wasn't Ben
when I accomplished all of his athletic
achievements of course yeah but that's
where it's weird right it's like he did
everything spectacular with me and now
he's saying you don't need it yeah yeah
it's pretty later he's part time vegan
he's saying in this article now now like
two years after that Epic Meal Time
thing Oh concept like how are you part
vegan you know I'm sure vegans would
take issue with that all right guy you
know arguing with someone about this
once I talked about this he said I'm 90
percent vegetarian and this was his
argument like that like vegetarians way
to go I'm ninety percent vegetarian like
[ __ ] that's zero it's even more
ridiculous with vegan because there's a
fire before all it takes sometimes a
little because like organ meats and
shellfish and fish and eggs are so
nutrient dense you don't have to eat a
lot of them to get to get the meat your
nutrition I had this conversation with
vegans too about mollusks and I was like
you know I've heard it argued and Sam
Harris was talk to me about this that
you can actually make an ethical
argument that mollusks are more
primitive than plants and that plants
actually exchange more information
through mycelium to the root structure
and they actually communicate with each
other evidence of intelligence yeah
they're the moths are an older creature
and they're they're just dumb hunks of
meat you could scoop out of a container
I mean they have no idea you're there
they have just basic movement with a
clamp shut that's it I mean they're not
going stop no they're not trying to get
away like a fish mollusks just [ __ ]
lay there and they happen to be like I
said among the most nutrient-dense food
on the planet like one serving of
oysters I think will meet your need for
a sing for the entire week
yes that's pretty mean so that's we're
talking about yes and that's always been
associated with male virility yeah so
many different functions it's also
owners who should have done that test
right eat a bunch of oysters imagine
that ready eight times more than the
guys who were eating plants for the ring
around their penis
[Applause]